é mais fácil para o homem conquistar uma
cidade inteira do que dominar o próprio
espírito é verdade
afinal ninguém pode dominar aquilo que
não conhece
se eu quero conhecer o idioma eu devo
estudar lo e eu quis me conhecer
eu quis me olhar no espelho só que o meu
espelho foi um espelho diferente um
cavalo
vocês devem estar perguntando por que
cavalos o que que esse animal tão frágil
natureza e ao mesmo tempo tão imponente
tem para nos ensinar
este é um cavalo se chama galego eu
apelidei ele de brad pitt e essa
história que eu quero compartilhar com
vocês hoje como os cavalos ensinaram e
me ajudaram a tomar as rédeas da minha
vida eu sou descendente de índios nasci
numa fazenda no interior de minas gerais
em uma cidade chamada dores do turvo
se alguém aqui conhecer com certeza meu
parente
eu cresci vendo meu pai trabalhar com
cavalos
meu pai era um domador de cavalos eu
adorava ficar no alpendre da casa essa é
a casa que eu nasci na fazenda eu
adorava assistir o meu pai ali
trabalhando os cavalos o meu herói
e aquele animal tão fascinante e quando
me perguntavam o que você quer ser
quando crescer eu dizia eu quero ser uma
domadora de cavalos
meu pai falava do mar cavalos é coisa de
homem
o tempo foi passando e eu tive que ir
para a cidade grande estudar aos 14 anos
eu comecei a trabalhar e de lá pra cá eu
trabalhei como bancária no comércio
na indústria e hoje apesar de nunca ter
cursado universidade
eu sou um empresário no ramo de
logística internacional atuou na área do
petróleo e de construção
me considero uma mulher bem sucedida
porque pelo lado financeiro mas por que
eu construí uma empresa com muita ética
e com placar em si o que é muito difícil
na área em que o ato enquanto na minha
vida profissional
as coisas estavam indo bem eu sempre fui
muito guerreira e trabalhei duro passei
dificuldades
eu tive momentos na minha vida quando eu
comecei a trabalhar e eu não tinha
dinheiro nem pra comprar comida muito
guerreira muito brava no meu trabalho
muito exigente
eu tinha problemas de relacionamento com
os meus funcionários
então eu tinha um tornou viral tu meu
apelido era miranda do diabo veste prada
eu era difícil as pessoas tinham medo de
mim muito bem na vida pessoal eu cheguei
no meio fundo de poço quando eu me
separei tive problemas com os meus
filhos e passei por aquela situação que
acho que muitas pessoas também passaram
tive depressão tava mal come uma
autoestima baixa eu não gostava do que
eu via quando eu olhava no espelho e
decidi que era hora de mudanças
busquei ajuda fisioterapia
busquei leão alguns livros fiz vários
cursos num desses cursos de um instrutor
que parecia o capitão nascimento
ele gritava quem é você
aquele exercício me fez meditar e
perguntava quem é você sou empresário
sua mãe sou guerreira não o que sempre
esteve com você o que sempre pertenceu e
um dia vendo um filme bater lista
eu decidi ir em busca de mim mesmo quem
é maria dalva e eu percebi que eu não
sabia nada sobre mim eu tinha trabalhado
eu tinha conquistado muitas coisas mas
não sabia nada sobre a maria dalva
fiz essa lista busquei coisas lá da
minha infância do mar cavalos porque um
dia que se a domadora de cavalos
eu precisava em busca dessa pista
talvez a influência do meu pai e do meu
herói ou realmente era uma coisa que
ficava dentro de mim e fui atrás da
primeira pizza e tomei uma decisão
comprei um cavalo eu queria um cavalo
branco não precisava do preço do cavalo
já estava bom e eu comecei a interagir
com este cavalo de uma maneira eu queria
fazer dele um cachorro estava na hípica
e eu comecei a interagir com esse cavalo
eu brincava com ele e me seguia e eu
tentava me comunicar com ele
eu gostava muito dos momentos que eu
passava com um dia um amigo me viu e
falou 'se você conhece a comunicação
homem cavalo que é uma técnica chamada
horse meat chip é a linguagem é como se
eu falei como nunca ouvi falar
o rio a internet e notei lahóz somente
descobri que tinha um curso de doma
racional em sorocaba
não pensei duas vezes fiz a minha
matrícula e lá fui eu
chegando lá eu vi que só tinha homens
lembrei do meu pai do mar cavalos é
coisa de homem
mas mesmo assim eu decidi ficar eu
estava fascinada de conhecer um pouco
mais preocupou de me comunicar melhor
com o meu cavalo
o professor doutor fernando rolin um
médico veterinário e se especializou nos
estados unidos em comportamento dos
cavalos e ele explicando sobre a
hierarquia social dos cavalos
ele começou um curso falando sobre isso
falando que na natureza os cavalos são
divididos em um grupo de oito a doze
indivíduos
esse grupo tem o dominante ele
conquistar essa posição através do
controle de movimento e de espaço do
grupo por exemplo grupo grupo tá bebendo
água
ele chega de esse espaço é meu
e aí todo o grupo tem que se afastar e
ele tomada
tem também o líder essa posição
normalmente a conquistada pela égua alfa
a égua mais velha do grupo
a fêmea só isso
a facilitadora do grupo e ela leva o
grupo pra água de melhor qualidade da
comida de melhor qualidade então ela se
preocupa com o grupo e tem os seguidores
todos seguem o líder é inclusive o
dominante que eu prestava atenção está
baixando interessante e ele começou a
dizer nós seres humanos somos os maiores
predadores da face da terra
este animal não escolheu estar aqui nós
temos olhos na fronte
nós temos orelhas voltadas para trás
como felinos prontos a atacar nós temos
garras e produzimos ferramentas que
matam
portanto ao se relacionar com o cavalo
você deve escolher se você quer ser o
dominante ou se você quer ser um líder
para ele te seguir você deve desenvolver
habilidades de liderança
o final do curso foram cinco dias
eu aprendi a domar cavalos e muito mais
do que isso
do meio professor me casei com ele
o professor me perguntaram se essa foto
é uma montagem não é verdadeiro eu casei
subir em cima de um cavalo e foi pra
casa pagar esse mico sonho tudo pode
eu continuei praticando horse mente pe
o que que isso trouxe pra minha vida pra
me relacionar com um cavalo
eu tive que desenvolver a habilidade da
égua alfa
eu tive que melhorar a minha comunicação
porque o cavalo ele reage de acordo com
a minha linguagem corporal
eu chegava lá queria que ele fizesse as
coisas ele não reage a eu tive que
controlar minha energia tive que tomar a
forma como eu interagia com ele eu tive
que melhorar a minha comunicação e
melhorar a minha forma de de se
relacionar porque eu queria muito
crescer com aquele animal e isso trouxe
um reflexo muito positivo na minha
empresa refletiu na minha forma e eu
percebi que eu era uma grande dominante
uma predadora e eu comecei a olhar com
outros olhos a pensar com uma égua alfa
e me preocupar com o bem estar do outro
eu comecei a melhorar os meus
relacionamentos dentro da minha empresa
já não era mais a miranda do diabo veste
prada
eu quero exemplificá pra vocês eu vou
colocar dois vídeos eu fiz esses vídeos
poucos dias antes dessa reunião aqui o
mesmo cavalo no mesmo dia no primeiro
vídeo eu me comporto como a predadora
como a dominante a minha linguagem é de
um dominante né a minha comunicação ele
não estava entendendo que eu queria
vocês vão ver a reação do cavalo
no segundo vídeo eu me comporto na
sequência com esse mesmo cavalo como um
líder
vou colocar pra vocês ele
e assim era também nos meus
relacionamentos as pessoas tinham medo
de mim era mais fácil fugiam
segundo o vídeo já o comportamento de
igual
para dar mais um exemplo
eu quero lembrar do filme avatar ele
resolve ir e se transformar num avatar
então ele monta num cavalo ele pega o
cabelo dele conecta no rabo do cavalo e
quando ele conecta o cavalo sente a
energia dele e pula e joga no chão
porque a energia não estava equilibrada
nessa conexão o cavalo se assustou e
depois no final do filme vocês vêem que
ele toma uma ave gigantesca que ninguém
havia tomado ele criadas exatamente
assim que eu me sinto quando eu montei o
meu cavalo centralizada eu diria eu me
sinto como se eu tivesse com quatro
patas
isso é conexão e é isso que eu quero me
conectar verdadeiramente com as pessoas
diz levar essa experiência para dentro
da minha empresa eu levei todos os meus
funcionários para interagir com o cavalo
e fazer o curso de horse mentir e foi
muito incrível porque eu conhecia os
funcionários eu sabia como cavalo ea
reagir quando eles entravam para se
conectar com o cavalo então tive um
feedback maravilhoso isso foi
experiência muito gratificante
nós também eu e meu marido fizemos uma
experiência no orfanato lá em brasília
levamos os nossos cavalos e ficamos lá
um período com as crianças para
trabalhar a autoestima a trabalhar a
confiança
então foi um trabalho muito gratificante
que nós fizemos e é isso que a gente
quer fazer e ter isso como missão
eu continuo no aprendizado e na busca
por mim mesma eu quero terminar a nossa
conversa lembrando da minha avó que
morreu ano passado aos 103 anos de idade
que ela me dizia não deixe a vida te
levar
tome as rédeas na sua mão ea conduza
eu tomei as rédeas da minha vida eu
estou aprendendo cada dia mais quem é
maria dalva tô tendo a coragem acho que
meu maior desafio olhar pra dentro de
mim saber quem eu sou
entender que todos nós temos uma missão
que todos nós diferentes mas somos
feitos do mesmo produto com as nossas
falhas com as nossas fraquezas com os
nossos anseios com os nossos sonhos e eu
queria ser uma domadora de cavalos
acabei sendo tomada por eles muito
obrigado